hey everybody welcome back to fantasy
Valley this video is a little bit
unusual and I know I've been saying that
on way too many videos recently but
trust me this one is actually a bit
weird at least for me in that I'm not
going to be building any buildings so if
you're here for that kind of stuff I am
very sorry but that's not who I have in
this video basically I was looking at
the park and figuring I didn't really
know what to do next and as much as I
usually like to do the buildings first
before I get into anything else this
area has a lot of the focus on gardening
or many paths works that are just well
still unfinished and lying around that
still needed a lot of work to be done
and just a lot of general emptiness that
I wasn't really sure how to fill it in
and it seemed like the best approach in
this case is actually to start off with
everything but the buildings first
create a good idea of what this area is
going to look like and then fill it in
with the buildings afterwards I just
usually like to get in the buildings and
just kind of fill that in later and hope
for the best but in this case I figure
it's a bit too important to know what
the rest of the area is going to look
like to be able to fit in the building's
pretty much in the way that I want to
which all sounds like I planned this
ahead quite a lot but I didn't really it
just kind of felt best when I was
recording this and you might also notice
I took a bit of Liberty there to record
off-screen for a bit and made that
bridge over there which I hope to do a
bit more in the future as well there's
still some bridges to be made but this
one was particularly annoying because I
don't really like it that much but it
does cover an in-game path and the
in-game paths don't really have the
exact shapes and like angles that I
would have loved for this kind of bridge
which made it a lot well harder than it
could have been since instead of just
building a bridge in the way that I
wanted to it does kind of need to
conform to the path in the game but in
the end I'm quite happy with it and just
reserving final judgement until the area
is more or less more finished and you
actually have a good idea of what it's
going to look like which I didn't really
talk about
much so far basically I have this little
pond going over here with the curve that
kind of swoops over it very much like
mentor and a large circular path or well
it's semicircular on the other side
which I'll have a bit of a small tea
house on one side as well and the idea
there was mostly to get a good place for
a sight line because this is going to be
a place from which you can see the
coaster the mountain the pagoda and
everything on the side pretty much from
one angle and for me personally at least
it's one of my favorite angles to look
at this entire hill from and it's one
that I always kind of built it for and
it's a really important little place for
that and that's why I wanted to make it
quite open and also leave it open for a
future tea house with a small Terrace to
be able to actually use and keep that
sight line as much as I can and just to
make things a little bit more
interesting I also wanted to quickly
build a gong over here which I didn't
have much else than a hamburger four so
this is now a gong made out of hamburger
but it works pretty well actually and
I'm quite happy with how it turned out I
forgot to actually use some island to
hang it from while I was recording this
but I did go back to it and quickly
replace that so that's all fine and
that's pretty much as quickly building a
simple gong there now as an almost final
decoration for this fence this very
simple stone kind of Asian fence which
was looking still a bit boring since it
doesn't really have too much foliage
aside from it I wanted to quickly add
some planters on the side of it and
that's pretty much all I wanted to do in
that curve for the time being then the
next couple of things that I wanted to
do is make the path how pretty much this
big mess of paths over here look a
little bit more organized and a bit more
like what I was going for
I still think personally it's quite hard
to go exactly for the very wide open
plaza like feeling that I wanted to get
with this area especially with the fact
that there is so much terraforming over
here and
can't make wide stretches of paths on a
hill so I'm trying to fill this in as
much as I can with scenery items which
means that it's not going to actually be
functional which is a bit of a shame but
all of these little parts I think are
very good for adding some smaller
sidewalks and paths areas where you can
just sit down have some benches have
some part elements and create those
smaller parts of the park where you can
just relax for a bit and also make some
better use of the space that I have over
here and then all of the areas in
between of these paths and these fences
and everything is more or less going to
be some simple Gardens with a bunch of
pretty straightforward foliage and
between that kind of like I did with
this little seating area over here I'll
just be using a lot of rocks to kind of
blend everything together it does feel a
little bit cheap but I do kind of like
using it just to cover up areas that
don't really come out that well like
parts where the terraforming isn't
really that great or where there's a
small corner of a building or path piece
that you have to cover up Rock work is
usually pretty handy to just cover up
all of the not so neat looking things
now it also helps a little bit since the
foliage of this area isn't going to be
that interesting I might still get back
to it if I have some time to experiment
with it a bit more because it does seem
like a really cool idea to build some
custom trees and bushes and play with
those but I don't go too much into
making like very beautiful ground
Gardens with all kinds of sculptures and
shapes and flowers and things like that
just because you don't really see that
in Asian gardening if you look at
Chinese and Japanese gardening it's a
lot more natural kind of gardening than
you would see in western gardens
especially in Japan that I know of
they're really trying to get a very
natural look into gardens which means
that I don't be playing around with any
kind of shapes in flowerbeds and things
like that and I just want to mostly keep
it to a bunch of different small bushes
here and there definitely - wanna play
around
with the flowers in a more interesting
way in the future but for this area it
doesn't seem like something that I
really wanted to that much maybe like a
topiary dragon would be cool but yeah
we'll see if that's gonna happen in the
future what I didn't want to do though
is create a slightly bigger tree that
kind of looks like I have one of these
Japanese spruces it definitely kind of
doesn't but at least it comes closer
when it comes to shape than all of the
trees that we have in game another
reason that I do want to watch out with
these kinds of trees is that so far it
does seem like most of the lag in this
park is actually going to be in the
trees I know that I'm putting loads of
different pieces into these buildings
especially in the Asian area but so far
I'm not actually too concerned about my
frame rate I am quite concerned about
how it's going to be at the end of the
park but it's still about 40 and I
started off with about 80 which is
already half of the frame rate but that
won't get too bad too soon so I'm not
too worried about that but I did make a
park where I put a lot of foliage in
just the kind of test how that frame
rate would be and that turned out a lot
worse than this Park even with a very
small amount of foliage so that's kind
of a positive thing because it means
that the trees are going to be the
biggest lag factor at some point
probably at least knowing how I am gonna
want to do the foliage but on the other
hand it does mean that I can't go into
foliage fully until the park is almost
finished and the performance isn't much
of a problem anymore which is a good
thing at least to know but it is kind of
ashamed exfoliates does really make
things look a lot better anyway moving
on to the next thing I just quickly made
that support underneath the flying
coaster just because it lost its support
when I changed that a little bit just to
hopefully make that curve a bit less
forceful as you can see I did move it
down like I think I said before just to
keep the forces a bit lower and I also
did change the tide look on the coaster
but there was a support cone because
with an and I quickly had to repair that
the next thing that I wanted to do is
create a small waterfront which
basically there will be water phones
around the entire Lake and I might play
around with the themes a little bit and
make the water phones kind of look like
the things that they are supposed to be
in but I'm mostly just going to keep
them quite neutral so I'm not going to
really do too much theming around this
thing just making a quick small area
where you could sit down next to the
water and I wanted to do a bit more like
well yeah put a bit more attention into
the rock work here and kind of really
make it look like there's sedimentary
layers in a way that I got moved and
rotated over time which isn't exactly a
thing that I did before and it's
something which I did try with in game
terraforming too as much as I would have
loved to see it realistically I wasn't
able to make it look good at all but at
least with this kind of rock I think it
looks a little bit thick a little bit
better than just putting some random
rocks on each other without any kind of
shape so this is probably what I'll
trying to do a bit more in the future of
this park as well I'm still playing
around with stuff and whatever looks
best as well this is just a simple
little test anyway and of course I also
had to make sure that the paths are
actually connected to the real paths so
put some wide staircases around the
entire thing so that theoretically in a
perfect world you could just kind of sit
down there and have a look at the water
and see all of the other themes on the
other side of the lake which is not
quite happening yet but it also works
the other way around
I wanted to keep this very open well
water from here just to keep the sight
line from the other side of the lake on
to their Japanese / Chinese area open
which is why I just placed two very
small trees there I don't put too much
foliage or any buildings over here just
to keep quite open there and lastly I'm
just putting a bunch of my bushes on all
of the rocks just because that always
makes
look a little bit better I think now
another thing that I wanted to do in
this video and this turned out to become
quite a time-consuming thing but it's
pretty important for the rest of the
Japanese area it's making this Plaza
with the small barrel ferris wheel kind
of thing which I did get comments about
that it's not the most fitting thing to
put into an Asian area which I
completely agree with I was actually
hoping to put the rock spurs over there
I'm not trying to
well penalty any Japanese animation
things there but um I just figured that
would fit mostly into the theme with
like seafood and all that and I would
have loved to see it but it seemed like
it's a little bit too big to actually
turn the plaza and what I was hoping to
do since this should be quite a wide
Plaza more about that a little bit later
in this video especially in the real
time section but I wanted to keep this
Vlasov very wide and have some buildings
on the side and the rock surface was too
big and all of the other rides were way
too big and a carousel or something of
that nature it doesn't really fit into
this kind of area so this seemed like
the closest to the theme while at the
same time being small enough to fit in
the plaza which is why I went with this
I do think it could have fit better in a
different theme but this just kind of
fits best in the space that we have here
which is also kind of limited because I
wanted to make this bus a bit more
interesting by having the different
heights of the paths instead of just
having one big concrete area which
doesn't really have anything interesting
going for it this little wall with a
bunch of rock work in the future and
some foliage should at least make the
plaza a bit more interesting and a
cooler area to sit around in so that's
why I wanted to get this in here and
you'll have like places on the top floor
in a way and places on the bottom floor
that you can sit on and
well do whatever you really want to do
in this area just kind of watch the
coaster go by or watch your children in
the ferris wheel something like that and
finish that off with rook work what else
just because the terraforming was
looking a little bit messy there but
most of the time in this kind of thing
was in the end spent on getting all of
these like strange and awkward sections
of paths with all of their curves and
well points sticking out to actually
have some paths work looking things by
using scenery pieces which isn't very
good for the framerate and it's also not
very good for me since it takes a lot of
time to do but it's really just by the
only way to get this kind of custom path
work in so that's what we're going for
here
I might actually make some of these
functional which is a thing for many of
these areas I could also have some like
real in-game parts go underneath them so
that people can actually walk over them
but in many cases it doesn't really seem
like it's necessary anyway and I'm just
mostly making this Park for the looks
and I reckon this will look more or less
fine with guests walking around the main
points of the road instead of the plazas
or instead of the sidewalks but we'll
see about that in the future the way
that this Plaza is going to be made by
the way is it's going to be quite wide
with these grey sidewalks on both of the
sides and the queue is just about where
the building is going to start with like
an overhanging roof to kind of give a
counterweight to all of the pretty tall
buildings on the other side of the plaza
because I was afraid with getting this
very large hill in the middle of this
Asian area that it wouldn't feel like
like a closed area like usually I think
an area works best if it has large
buildings around it and you kind of feel
immersed in the theme and you don't
really see all of the other themes
around it which is why I kind of want to
go for that bowl kind of building thing
where you have buildings all around it
and a plaza in the middle and it's hard
to make that kind of thing if you have a
hill right in
the area and that's why I Hannah's still
wanted to create almost a ring of
buildings around this hill with the
plaza in between those two buildings if
that makes any sense basically to create
a large ring of large buildings and
foliage around the plaza so they you
can't really see the other areas but you
are still pretty much surrounded by lots
of Asian scenery speaking of Asian
scenery by the way I'm not going to be
doing any of the real path like
essentials in this video yet well I will
do quite a bit of it but not really
finishing off the web parts in a way
that I would want to do it but what I
did want to do already is add some light
posts and experiment a bit with the
lights and make some custom Asian
looking lights and I was struggling with
this for quite a bit since well I didn't
know what kind of color scheme and look
I wanted to have for these lamp posts
but actually having Asian looking lights
was kind of a struggle for a bit and in
the end what I went with is actually
having these hanging lights in which
you'll see in a bit which are like yeah
these very red kind of lantern looking
lights I'm not too sure how much I like
them but from a distance they kind of
look like Asian lanterns and that's why
I figured I would use them I will mix
them up a little bit with the more
standard lanterns since you do see them
in Asia as well but just again the mood
in there I wanted to play around with
the red lights for a bit that sounds bad
anyway moving on this is like playing
with the other lampposts that I want to
make a little bit I did change these
off-screen in the end with like some
small tweaks here and there to make them
look a little bit better I think but the
basic way that these things are made
it's just quite easy and quite a lot of
fun to play with just one quick poll and
a bunch of smaller scenery items let's
get some decoration onto it and play
around with all of the different lights
to see which light would fit best on it
and pretty much leave it out there and
copy it over once it's good to go and
there's a bunch of different things that
you can do with the lights once you sort
get the base of it done you could just
pop a quick light straight on the center
of it like I just did there or you could
have two on the sides or you can have
four or have hanging ones instead so I
played around with those a bit and there
will be a bit of a variety of different
ones around the area but one different
lights that I still wanted to make as
well is actually a really small one just
for the size of the bridge since I
didn't have anything for it yet and it
seemed like the best thing to put on the
bridge would be a very small Knights for
just the corners of it
so that's the very last thing that I
wanted to do very quickly here so I just
made some bases out of some scenery
pieces and I'll put a light on it and
that should do that now that's it for
the time that spot I'm gonna give it
over to my old self to give you some
real-time talk all right I didn't get as
much done in this episode as always
hoping to just because the paths and the
lay how it's turned out to be a little
bit more time-consuming than I was
figuring beforehand but with two more
episodes I think we'll be finishing this
episode this is what with two more
episodes we'll be finishing this part of
the park and the stuff that I still want
to do in those episodes are quite
clearly demarcated and like open right
now so figuring out the layouts and
where to place certain things should be
much of a worry anymore and it's more
just kind of filling in the things that
are still blank so some of the things
that are still blank but that I really
want to get to in the next two videos is
a tea house over here which is like the
big plan thing that I've always wanted
to do here mostly because this is a
super important sight line and just
about the place where the coaster looks
best and when you have that waterfront
with the coaster and the facades in the
distance just a nice place to sit down
and have a quick self-service restaurant
kind of thing with a bit of a terrace as
well probably because I don't really
have that kind of thing yet and it's
pretty necessary since this is a theme
park also there will be a row for Sansa
over here which is going to be the
border between the East Asian and the
Arabic section of the park not really
sure how it's going to work out
and I might feel a bit of it over here
with some foliage as well but that's
really going to set the scene for the
Asian area as well as just be a good way
to get a very quick and narrow border in
between these episodes or keys in
between these parts of the park I don't
know why I keep saying the word episode
but yeah that should hopefully be a way
to not just leave a lot of space for the
Arabic area but also make sure that you
don't see too much of the other areas as
you're in another area just to make sure
that you know you're not taken out of
the immersion of the theme that you're
going to be in and the same kind of goes
for this border over here where we're
gonna have the Southeast Asian part and
I'm probably gonna have a row of
buildings it's definitely gonna be a
building to give the backdrop to this
ride this Plaza and be the opposite side
of the large winding area of the Asian
area but I'm not really sure if I'll
make this part in the middle of building
or if I'll just have a bit of forest
over here and but the way that I am
going to set up this Plaza it's not
really finished yet as you can see I
still need to add all of the path
elements and a lot of detailing to this
but the reason why this is so open and
set up in such a way is because I wanted
to keep that sight line of having a spot
where you could sit down right here and
or just walk around on this large Plaza
but basically see this big curve that
kind of gives you a row of the biggest
things there are to see in this area
that really set the scene here so we
have the pagoda the coaster the facades
here maybe a bit of Foresti in-betweener
to fill up the gaps and the station all
the way on the right and I'm quite happy
with how that turned out and obviously
the most important sight line which I'll
also have to keep track of is from the
lake as you look from the other side of
the lake or as you look from over here
basically straight onto the Asian area
where you can kind of see how
everything's gonna be filled in we'll
have maybe a bit of a building here
maybe some taller foliage the facades
over here to fill in what's very empty
right now
same goes for the other side and maybe a
little bit more detailing in the middle
but I do want to keep this very open
just to be able to still see all of the
like the rock work and the way that
everything is set up right now and I was
figuring for quite a while I could have
an Asian gate which has been like
recommended a couple of times in the
comment sections but I will actually
keep this space open just so you can
clearly see how everything looks from a
distance so that's really all of my
planning I'm not really sure what kind
of order I'll get into all of those
things but that's what I'm gonna do in
the next videos so thank you guys for
watching and I hope to see you guys next
time